well we'd stand in total solidarity with
the nine individuals that were
sanctioned today
it's not going to stop them it's not
going to stop the british government
speaking up about the industrial scale
human rights abuses taking place in
xinjiang
that was the british foreign minister
rejecting sanctions imposed
on the uk on uk individuals rather by
china
an apparent bit of tit for tat after
britain
along with the european union the u.s
and canada sanctioned
several chinese over allegations of
human rights abuses in the muslim
majority xinjiang province
while the chinese sanctions are aimed at
nine
british individuals and four
organizations british
prime minister boris johnson responded
on twitter saying all of those targeted
were shedding light
on gross human rights violations china
denies the allegations and calls
xinjiang an internal affair
after announcing those sanctions against
these
british individuals the chinese
government also
warned there could be further
retaliatory action
if the uk did not change course
china is determined to safeguard its
national sovereignty security and
development interests
and warns the uk not to go further down
the wrong path
let's speak now to helena kennedy member
of the house of lords in the uk and one
of the people that china has imposed
sanctions on a very good day ms kennedy
why do you think you were targeted
well because i have been quite outspoken
um
in parliament and beyond about what is
happening to the
muslim uyghur in in china
and i think that robust
calling out of china's behavior
is something that is considered
unacceptable to uh to china
it's not given to freedom of expression
no obviously this is not the first time
that you did it do you know why in terms
of the timing why now
yeah i i've been working on on issues
issues to do with human rights
and china for some years i'm a human
rights lawyer i'm i'm a
barrister here in england and i
and i run an institute of human rights
and i also
i'm a member of the house of lords i'm a
parliamentarian i'm in the legislature
and we've recently been calling upon the
british government
uh to create um uh uh to make a decision
about uh whether
you should trade with a country that
might be committing genocide
and and the evidence has been coming
through
very clearly particularly over the last
few years
that what is happening to the uyghur has
all the pointers
of of of genocide taking place
that people are having their identity
removed their their sense of themselves
as muslims
as as people who speak uh their own
language
people who have their own culture that
that's not to be allowable
inside contemporary china
and so they are experiencing terrible
abuses of human rights
on an industrial scale to use the words
of our
foreign secretary and so we were urging
the the government to create
sanctions against leading chinese
officials and we were calling upon our
government
to have in mind when they are making
trade negotiations
um that uh it would be absolutely
abhorrent
to be trading with a nation that was
conducting a genocide
well let's talk about that i want to
play uh you something that british prime
minister boris johnson said last week
before the announcement
of today's sanctions about china take a
listen
there is no question that china will
pose a
great challenge for an open society such
as ours but we will also
work with china where that is consistent
with our values and interests including
building a stronger and positive
economic relationship
and in addressing climate change
now miss kennedy prime minister boris
johnson there is straddling two things
and
in all fairness he's not the only
western leader to do this decoupling
human rights
issues from economic interest is it
possible to compartmentalize
values and trade basically have you know
the cake and eat it as well
i think i think that um every government
is faced with this kind of challenge
um and and of course uh nations insist
that they're sovereign and that what
happens within their own boundaries
on uh their own borders um is no
business of anybody else
but it is our business when it comes to
egregious human rights abuse abuses
um and we're not just talking here about
minor crimes we're talking about
uh really egregious and serious crime
now um um you know we we learned from
the holocaust
that you can't be a bystander you can't
basically close your eyes when something
terrible is happening
in in a country and it is it is right
and proper
that we should step forward and say what
you're doing is unacceptable
now i i too want china to uh
come into uh the embrace of um
international order the rules base that
we uh
where it's created after the second
world war i too want them to collaborate
with us
uh not just on climate change which is
so pressing but also on trade
um but they can't do that they can't
have it always they can't do it if they
break this
the rules that were created to make our
our world more harmonious
and more respectful of the humanity of
everybody and what they are doing just
now in china
to the uyghur is to my mind
is now cumulatively meaning that there
is a genocide in progress
now what the genocide convention says to
us is that and when we sign up to it
this is what we sign up to
is that we're to prevent a genocide from
happening
not to wait until it has happened right
and so the duty is on us
now thank you so much very much helena
kennedy member of the house of lords
in the uk for joining us
you